vamos a dar paso a las noticias de la
economía de directo a América con
Daniela Blandón Daniela Buen día para
usted Hola Ángela muy buenos días y
feliz viernes Igualmente para usted
Daniela Por fin es viernes Sí señora y
además un viernes que sigue trayendo
buenas noticias para su segmento el
mundo bursátil está de celebración
después del acuerdo en el congreso de
Estados Unidos para ampliar el techo de
la deuda y que el país no entre impuesto
Claro que sí Ángela por eso y también
por muchas otras razones las acciones
globales y las materias primas subieron
este viernes Mientras que el dólar se
dirigía a su mayor caída semanal desde
marzo esto por qué Porque la confianza
del mercado se ha visto impulsada por
señales de que la reserva Federal se va
a saltar Un aumento de tasas de interés
en su próxima reunión y también por
supuesto por la aprobación de la ley del
techo de deuda en Estados Unidos en Asia
el principal índice de las acciones
japonesas el níquel cerró en un máximo
de tres décadas ya que esta aprobación
del pacto en Estados Unidos le dio un al
mercado financiero de todo el mundo pues
un incumplimiento de Estados Unidos en
sus obligaciones hubiera tenido
consecuencias globales catastróficas
como ellos mismos lo han dicho Daniela
es importante de todas maneras que
hagamos un alto en el camino porque Más
allá de la celebración hay que ver qué
fue lo que aprobaron no Y usted nos va a
contar claro y primero Entonces vamos a
hacer como un repaso Y es que a
diferencia de la mayoría de los demás
países desarrollados Estados Unidos
limita la cantidad de deuda que el
gobierno puede pedir prestada
independientemente de los gastos que
hayan sido asignados por la legislatura
Y en este país tanto los gastos como la
deuda han venido en aumento con esta
legislación Entonces que lleva meses
negociándose por los líderes de los
partidos demócrata y republicano es el
límite legal de los préstamos federales
que hoy es de 31,4 billones de dólares
se va a suspender hasta el primero de
enero de 2025 es decir que se ahorran
todo ese debate político al menos hasta
que pasen las próximas elecciones
presidenciales el proyecto a jueves por
el senado y que ya debe estar en el
escritorio de Joe biden para su firma
evita lo que habría sido el primer
incumplimiento de pago en la historia
del país
hemos salvado el país del flagelo de la
suspensión de pagos a pesar de que había
algunos del otro lado que querían esa
suspensión puede que estemos un poco
cansados pero lo logramos Así que
estamos muy muy contentos el default era
la espada gigante que colgaba sobre la
cabeza de Estados Unidos pero debido al
buen trabajo del Presidente biden así
como de los demócratas en la cámara y en
el senado no estamos incumpliendo Ángela
Y puede que estén muy felices como él
mismo lo dice pero si bien está amarga
batalla ya terminó los legisladores ya
se preparan para la próxima 12 proyectos
de ley en los que trabajará el congreso
durante el verano para financiar
programas gubernamentales del año fiscal
que comienza el primero de octubre
algunos de los cuales serán precisamente
un desarrollo de este proyecto de ley de
límite de deuda y los republicanos
destacan que lograron algunas
concesiones
no solo les dimos los mayores ahorros en
la historia de Estados Unidos sino que
hoy habrá personas que recibían
asistencia social y ya no lo harán
encontrarán un trabajo debido a los
nuevos requisitos aprobados su
autoestima sus actitudes van a cambiar
van a creer en sí mismos van a poder
comprar una casa enviar a sus hijos a la
universidad gracias a la votación que
hicimos esta noche
con seguridad de aquí en adelante no
será fácil pero eso es parte del
ejercicio de la Democracia del consenso
el disenso y para eso están ahí los
representantes claro y para eso cada uno
tiene su propia mayoría Entonces eso le
da más digamos más debate al tema Bueno
pues tienen ellos que impulsar sus
agendas y mientras continúan en Estados
Unidos con ello Yo quisiera que
pasáramos a otro tema Daniela más bien
delicado la ONU está denunciando que
Rusia está entorpeciendo el acuerdo de
granos que permite que estos sal desde
Ucrania y aquí pues se ponen otra vez
las cosas complejas Ángela y cómo nace
todo esto pues hace casi un año Naciones
Unidas y Turquía negociaron esta
iniciativa para que puedan salir
alimentos desde Ucrania mientras se
desarrolla la guerra en mayo se aprobó
una nueva extensión de dos meses de este
acuerdo que cubre tres puertos
ucranianos sin embargo
Moscú ha amenazado constantemente
compararlo si no se superan los
obstáculos a sus propias exportaciones
de granos y de fertilizantes la ONU
confirmó que el kremlin bloqueó
parcialmente el registro de barcos en
estos puertos ucranianos Y eso hace que
se retrase más la operación
nos preocupa la continua ralentización
de la implementación de la iniciativa
del mar Negro observada particularmente
en los meses de abril y mayo en mayo 33
barcos partieron de puertos ucranianos
la mitad En comparación con abril
solo tres de esos barcos partieron de
los acuerdos de Junior Benji uno de los
tres puertos u cubiertos por el acuerdo
Daniela que esto no es un titular de hoy
Ucrania lleva ya semanas haciendo estas
denuncias de bloqueos en los registros
de los barcos inclusive desde que inició
este acuerdo hace un año casi no Claro
es que han sido constantes los frenos
que se les ha puesto a este a este
acuerdo que pues además es entre dos
países en guerra Daniela no se esperaba
menos vamos a pasar a otra noticia un
poco más amable va a salir a subasta una
serie de artículos para Los Amantes del
rock usted nos cuenta más bueno le
interesa o no le interesa no Pero por
supuesto
pondrá a la venta miles de pertenencias
de nadie más y nada menos que de Freddie
Mercury algunas valoradas en cientos de
miles de dólares entre ellas un borrador
del éxito histórico del bohemian
rhapsody unos trazos en su borrador han
revelado un secreto sobre la historia de
esa canción los detalles a continuación
es una de las canciones de Rock más
famosas e inusuales que dominó las
listas de éxitos y vendió millones de
copias pero la bohemian rhapsody que
muchos conocemos y amamos hoy podría
haber sido muy diferente en un aspecto
un borrador de la canción escrito por
Freddie Mercury sugiere que una vez
estuvo en juego la idea de otro título
tachado pero aún legible en la parte
superior derecha del borrador hay un
garabato que dice mongolian rhapsody el
borrador es solo una de las más de 1000
pertenencias de Mercury que son de vista
cara a subasta en septiembre en nombre
de su vieja amiga Mary Austin sodevis
prevé que se venda por entre un millón y
uno coma tres millones de dólares
otros de los objetos subastados son el
catsut de satén Marfil que apareció en
el video musical de la canción en 1975
cuyo valor se estima entre 62 mil y 87
mil dólares
también se subastará lo que se cree que
es el primer cuaderno de las letras de
Mercury que contiene versos del éxito
para nuestros televidentes también
pueden consultar la revista de prensa de
Marta Moya de este jueves en la que nos
cuenta un poco más de la historia de
este manuscrito y de esta canción pero
Gracias Daniela usted por traerlo
nuevamente a la mesa muy pendientes en
septiembre de esta subasta nos vemos
pronto bueno así es en una hora
[Música]